[Musique]
il était à la fois unique curieux mais
surtout mystérieux si je vous disais
qu'on vient d'ailleurs est ce que vous
vous croyez les frères bogdanov qui
l'ont quitté à ce jour d'intervalle
emportant avec eux des secrets encore
bien gardé ce qui est certain c'est que
la peur a déjà connu d'autres habitants
que nous les humains leurs funérailles
avaient lieu cet après-midi à paris à
l'église de la madeleine sur place
beaucoup de spectateurs et de nombreuses
personnalités sont venues leur rendre
hommage et leur dire un dernier au
revoir il était formidable moi j'ai les
députés qu hitler et datées kg après
leur défaite a été un choc pour nous
tous mais qui est-il vraiment était-il
annuler certaines maladies comme
certains le prétendent ont-ils eu
recours à quelconque chirurgie pour
n'était-il de leur vie privée et
questions autour de ce duo emblématique
sont sans limites et ce soir nous allons
vous dévoiler les plus grands secrets
encore jamais révélé sur ses frères
inséparables
merci à julien lepers que jamais il ne
sait qui est avec nos amis
merci d'être là mon julien merci
beaucoup merci jordan de luxe et merci
hameau des guillemins qui a écrit un
livre formidable mystère bogdanov on va
revenir sur les quinze secret des
bonhommes juste aujourd'hui bon vous y
étiez à la madeleine pour les vous étiez
à la madeleine pour pour les bogdanoff
joue sans stress française total j'ai
encore le coeur serré la terrible de
voir ces deux s'est enfin je vais pas
j'ai pas envie de tomber dans le deux
cercueils toute la famille un monde fou
à la madeleine maintien de fou et quand
on les a connus aussi bien que vous
quelques mois on a fait plein
d'émissions ensemble
la moindre des choses c'est qu'on y soit
et qu'on pense à eux beaucoup mais
exactement secrète de leur vivant de
leurs avoirs assedic on les aimait c'est
vrai je suis d'accord a été juste ça
j'ai un peu d'accord alors à 15 heures
autour de 15 heures il est 2 certaines
sont entrés dans l'église le moment
était très fort regardez vous pouvez
voir ces deux cercueils monter les
escaliers qui vont mener à l'église de
la madeleine en présence évidemment de
la famille des frères bogdanoff de
personnalités on peut citer notamment
leur ami luc ferry le philosophe et
ancien ministre de l'éducation on peut
citer encore raphaël enthoven il vient
également de la place pour pour les
badauds pour assister à ce dernier
hommage avant que les deux frères soit
inhumé dans le sud-ouest dans le gers
dans les prochains jours
alors à l'intérieur de l'église
l'ambiance est évidemment très solennel
pour ce dernier hommage regarde
[Musique]
génial je sais que tu es très et murano
revoir ça c'est vrai que c'était
vraiment des proches à toi est-ce que tu
savais qu'ils étaient malades de toi tu
savais qu'il avait contracté le comique
je l'aimais jeu un peu comme tout le
monde
oui oui oui mais je savais surtout qui
ne se soigne pas c'est ça pas de quinsac
là on va le dire tout à l'heure
macquarie capital
rien que ça il se soignait pas du tout
il estimé que justement parce qu'on a un
petit débat avec laurent alexandre golly
un peu le début moi je lui dis que c'est
parce que il ne se soignait pas aussi
qu'ils ont laissé traîner leur maladie
que malheureusement on en est arrivé là
aujourd'hui et vous vous dites c'est
parce qu'ils ne sont pas vaccinés écoute
luc ferry j'en ai beaucoup parlé avec
luc ferry qu'un prof très bons amis des
blogs il est aussi un de mes proches je
les adore luc l'udc était désespérée luc
15 fois acier des convaincre de se faire
vacciner il avait les larmes aux yeux
luc série quand il en parlait il a
essayé les deux il essayait de faire
vacciner sont jamais voulu parce
qu'effectivement il n'aimait pas la
médecine et les médecins donc il ya une
rumeur là qui circulent que les anti
vaccins font circuler depuis 48 heures
qui est qu'en fait c'est pas parce
qu'ils n'étaient pas vaccinés qui sont
morts c'est parce qu'ils auraient eu un
cancer c'est totalement faux il était en
bonne santé ils n'avaient pas de cancer
ils ont fait une forme grave et là sauf
à laisser les connaître ils ont mal et
franchement s'ils avaient été vaccinées
et s'il avait été soignée qui serait
encore là où j'en avais été soigné si tu
veux être soigné par quoi non mais il
était en réanimation non mais avant ils
ont récité moria pas de traitement
préventif du coc vide le truc que
personne ne prescrit de neupro protocole
pro sera houleux sur terre ni
l'ivermectine gare et à l'internement
des teintes et à la région
c'est une question de délaisser à
l'exception des matchs interligues était
d'accord mais bon je suis d'accord
une question de délai s'il avait été
soigné avant d'aller en réanimation
c'est ce qu'on dit avec cyril si si si
eux-mêmes s'était rendu compte ou avait
voulu se faire soigner avant quand ils
sont en arrivant à l'hôpital en
réanimation entre guillemets c'était
déjà très tard on va pas dire trop tard
mais très tôt mais avant il aurait pu se
faire soigner c'est pas une question de
vaccination médias sociaux sont aussi
c'est une question de vaccination il
n'aurait pas fait une forme grave s'il
avait été vacciné statistiques mais
jordan jordan du studio peut-être suivi
la faire puisque tu étais très proche
des bogdanoff aussi qu'est ce qui s'est
passé ben en fait ça qu'on n'a pas trop
trop compris parce qu'on a fait une
émission y'a pas très très long avec
julien d'ailleurs on avait bien rigolé
oui la f1 est un espèce de jeu de
lévitation ensemble ils étaient très
très en forme et c'est ça que ça va pas
toujours compte des bordels au niveau du
fatah tout ce qui était co vite tout ça
ça restait quand même très très segmenté
enfin qu'il faisait très attention mais
cependant on sentait qu'ils voulaient
pas se faire vacciner qui avait j'espère
que je m'investisse à un particulier par
rapport à ça et c'était limite un sujet
un peu tabou enfin moi je sais que
j'avais un peu évoqué ça avec eux c'est
un petit peu question de l'âge comme
tous ici cela qui me l'ont milieu ils
sont pas soignés ils se soignent et
jamais en fait n'ont jamais et ils n'ont
pas entre guillemets pris conscience ils
n'ont pas vu que c'était grave donc ils
ont laissé la maladie se propage et mais
honnêtement j'entends ce que vous dites
monsieur alexandre c'est pas une
question de vaccins mais bien sûr que
les sillons mais non bien sûr toto ne se
soigne pas comment que ce soit n'y
jamais du coup là on va pas soigner non
plus voilà c'est ça alors je pensais en
syrie il se pensait vraiment invincible
dans les émissions
jours oui mais ce départ mais là on
parle on parle médecine là c'est donc
passé hier dsk de il ya de jolis ils
vraiment ils iront il ya des nyalas yeux
qu'il y avait une chose est sûre bac
c'est hélas pas vacciner voilà oui et
tout le monde peut alors à la fin de la
cérémonie certains sont sortis de
l'église on a pu voir l'ex femme d'igor
et leurs enfants regarder
la cérémonie est en train de se terminer
les deux cercueils des deux frères igor
et grichka bogdanoff sont en train de
sortir avec juste la famille des deux
frères qui est en train de rentrer donc
un dernier hommage c'est très émouvant
évidemment et en même temps presque un
soulagement pour pour eux de les voir
partir ensemble puisque c'était
évidemment le plus important pour eux
c'était qu'ils puissent être unis
quoi qu'il arrive que ce soit dans la
vie mais également dans dans l'au delà
alors ma mère vous écrit un petit mot
allah dit que j'aime beaucoup le docteur
alexandre mais il y des bêtises il
aurait pu se soigner en prenant des
corticoïdes et des antibiotiques l
amateurisme et il a pas tort mais il a
pas tort ils ont envie de l'oxygène et
de la meinau mais là mais c'était trop
tard mais c'est non on va essayer ça va
et d'accor est non mais gilles tu peux
te connais tu prend dès que tu prends de
la cortisone et des antibiotiques
peut-être qu'il serait encore là
aujourd'hui et bien l'attraction année
près d'une affaire missiles tu prends de
la cortisone quand tu es à l'hôpital
avoir de quoi tu peux prendre du corps
cl ou dissolus prés d'arènes on dans le
cosby dont dominique corti sicile on le
donne à l'hôpital cissé mais si c'est ça
il pourra même sens qu'il faut donner
c'est de la dexaméthasone par voie
injectable ça se prend pas envie d'être
à leur écoute c'est pas une angine
contre est par contre il en médecine la
dexaméthasone il avait très vite et peut
être traitée très parlant aujourd'hui
guillaume 1,5 à une sans que moi je
trouve de récupération provoque ce qui a
été fait suite au décès des bogdanoff
quelques minutes après leur décès des
gens étaient déjà en train de dire bah
oui bah voila si ceux ci sont morts
c'est qu'ils sont pas vaccinés etc alors
évidemment c'est de l'émotionnel donc on
aime on a de la peine pour eux quand on
apprend qu'ils n'ont pas été vaccinés on
a envie de leur dire de se vacciner et
de là à faire de la récupération et dire
bah voilà fait de vous tous vaccinés
c'est un peu compliqué et que c est ma
mère teront répond elle te dis oui on
peut donner aux corps tantie oussou lui
près de sessa va donc ce match important
s'il condamnait le vide c'est de la
technique métal